rubrique faits divers pour la course
paris dakar la délinquance dans ce
désert ça existe aussi hier soir en
mauritanie des pillards ont dérobé des
véhicules de concurrents de la course
dans un scénario presque parfait
reportage d'un tonnelle de rincquesen
avec pierre lepetit
les recherches menées par hubert auriol
n'ont pas mis longtemps à aboutir
les trois camions dérobé cette nuit ont
été retrouvés complètement dépouillé à
quelques kilomètres seulement des lieux
du braquage
les pirates n'ont emporté que les objets
de valeur dans les cabines de pilotage
seuls les appareils électroniques ont
été dérobés l'armée mauritanienne sans
doute vexés par ce spectaculaire hold up
à repérer les traces des brigands mais
ils sont déjà loin
ce matin au bivouac lorsque les
concurrents se sont réveillés ils ont a
priori fier ce qui s'était passé sur la
tempe agit pas de l'argent tout ce
qu'ils veulent a le choix de 19 heures
jusqu'à minuit
ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu m
salle-canne pris la tête du bivouac
ces images ont été tournées sur les
lieux du braquage par gérard berliet un
des concurrents dévalisés quelques
minutes seulement après le départ des
pirates les 50 victimes ont mis le feu
aux herbes à chameau pour se réchauffer
pour se rassurer aussi et enfin pour
retrouver leur véhicule
éparpillés aux quatre coins des dunes
immobilisé pendant près de quatre heures
par des kalachnikovs ils ont pu donner
l'alerté grâce à un téléphone oublié par
les pirates
ensuite ils ont regagné le bivouac de
tichit en convoi pour la direction du
rallye mobilisés toute la nuit ce fait
divers n'a rien de rassurant
l'an passé déjà un camion avait été volé
et des voitures avaient été suivies des
coups de feu cette nuit personne n'a été
blessé mais à l'avenir il faudra sans
doute renforcer la sécurité dans cette
zone à risque
malgré la présence des militaires
mauritaniens nous ont gentiment donné
rendez vous à l'année prochaine ont
remercié parce qu'il est plein d'humour
en plus et peut-être même entre
nouakchott et dakar